hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to outlast
whistleblower I apologize on the delay
of this video I was caught up with many
other things and I was unable to record
it when I wanted oh I know where I am
wait a minute why didn't I go down here
when I was originally running away from
the psycho crazy guy this is where I
fell down the elevator and jabbed my leg
which explains why I'm currently
hobbling my way to escape and I I don't
know I saw this exit sign before and I
was like is this game about to be over
but apparently not because I need a key
okay so was that me or was that someone
else I need to turn on the volume
because I can't hear anything
vocational block may award
administrative block not god dammit geez
your stupid announcement why do you need
to be so douchey about things okay I am
actually I didn't think that I had a
battery but I'm gonna find another one
here and I'll be there I need to be much
more conservative about these batteries
because the last time I ran out I really
screwed me over and trying to find my
way to the exit but this seems much
better because I seem to have found a
kitchen I wonder if I'll find the crazy
guy wants to eat my giblets again the
other guy wanted to cut off my giblets
and this guy wants to eat them I don't
know if this guy's here actually you
know what I didn't want to say anything
but when I first saw or I first heard
the guys talking about the guy
downstairs and when I saw the first stop
oh hi hi there friend
looks like your hiding spot in world my
whoa my goodness what happened here that
is a lot of dead bodies I need to read
my note on whatever the hell that was
all about Journal no book watch fresh
hell is this a man's body oh that was
talking about the last one but oh my god
is this a guy that it was oh man my
goodness this guy is not very sane is he
wait oh these all victims are the other
guy I don't know if this is all from one
but man he had a lot of wives this if
this wasn't what he was hired about here
this game god it had a lot of detail put
into it I did notice though that some of
the animations were lacking
compared to the first game but I think
this is because they were on a time
crunch and they weren't able to put the
finesse on anything but this good lordy
lo o my worry why even bother having a
gymnasium veterans is gonna stay struck
no I was done with you I was done with
you I escaped from you where are you can
I hide in one of these lockers am I
supposed to where are you I thought that
I was done with you you crazy person do
beautiful man you it's just a shame
because I will not oh okay wait a minute
did I block that off or did someone else
block that off I can't remember wait a
minute I'm in the exact same business
I'm in the same building I was I didn't
escape anywhere I thought he was done
with me he said that he was done with
the [ __ ] like me and that's me and
everybody things with Marga Bly they
think of okay here we go why do I need
to go this way it's back the way I came
oh god no I prefer okay this is gonna be
good isn't it
this is gonna be great okay yeah trip a
little bit shadows real good here no
okay sorry I'll just grab the key and be
on my way now
where am I going I am NOT going to be
helped here thank you very much for not
okay little piggy no no little piggy
gonna go away now he done block my way
out
you mr. groom man mr. groom man you're a
bride-to-be was waiting for you on the
other side of there okay hi how you
doing
no thank you okay paddling away oh god
you're fast you're faster than me am i
crawling back go on go go go go go
move around and go don't forget about
everything God even if I had a bum leg I
wouldn't be slowing up like this go go
go please please go please go try by me
isn't he always right by me okay let's
go please go faster now jump buddy thank
you god damn it Jesus that assbag I
would rather deal with her I'll rather
deal with the guy that cooks me as
opposed to that guy carrying on into the
perfectly where normal world that I am
in this outlast game okay so where was
that door that needed a key I think this
is it God sorry please I was almost down
those elbows down Chris Walker please
he'll be okay
so it's a very you hate to imagine thank
you sorry
nice joke did you let me down don't tell
me I'm actually gonna die oh no no no no
no no something giggling whoa what what
happened what happened oh hi what
happened
I didn't even see what happened I'm
assuming that it's rigged broke because
oh hi okay thanks for holding my hand as
you pled out I'm gonna go escape now you
tie a douche god damnit although I have
to admit man I'm I'm one tough
son-of-a-bitch if that doesn't faze me
and I'm still hobbling along out of here
I gotta admit this guy's perseverance is
very good but either way I gotta say
like I really really like this DLC
because it has really memorable
characters in this short timeframe that
it is like it's actually a pretty
lengthy DLC by itself compared to the
main game which wasn't that long but
either way this is really cool with it
oh I could have just walked out here but
either way this is just really cool
because the first game had quite a few
memorable characters but they were
spread out over the game and there was a
lot of just generic characters at
certain points but this one like it's
really cool I really appreciate the
amount of work that was put into this
especially to make these terrifying
sequences with extremely unique people
and maybe I am not near the end of the
game because I'm going into the male
ward right now I'm guessing this guy
harvested all of his Brides from the
male ward know that what oh hey Wow oh
wait a minute no wait a minute I'm I am
I playing this while the guy is there is
miles Upshur there am I gonna see the
walrider holy crap this is amazing cuz
if that's to be understood and that
cross is probably signified that the
priest just burnt himself having sent
miles Upshur is actually here when the
12 hours passed I was still in the game
when miles Upshur entered oh my god
hello hey I saw that come back here
that's insane oh wait
oh my god it's guys I don't know oh is
him it's a guy but he's already dead oh
my god my mind is being blown right now
I don't know what else to do
wait a minute I can't go to them because
they will scourge me I know they well
they're here to eliminate everyone and I
probably look like a crazy psycho grab a
now all that morphogenetic nted crap
um okay tell anything that moves huh
alrighty then how about Nami the groom
thought me attractive so if you'd like
my body as opposed to having my dead
body unless you're into that I would
offer it to you as a sacrifice so that
means it's gotta be getting to the close
to the point in the game I guess I can
hurry a bit because I doubt that there
I'm just gonna walk into death I'm
pretty sure this is all intentional it's
totally awesome
dear Sirs the groundwork has been laid
to ensure a none event or Dolf wernicki
from structural and financial system
that mountain acid his advanced age
should alleviate any suspicions among
contractors employees and legally
speaking he died years ago
I understand patients blah blah blah
blah blah blah and blah blah blah have
already been scheduled for transit we're
all terribly excited in an obvious
profit potential of the new project my
researchers have combed through the
Wernicke's files and found no mention of
the three lucid dreamers I think we can
safely assume wernicke was officially
distracted by the partial success of
patient Bailey hope along with his own
infirmity to be ignorant of the real
discoveries hand even minimal
exploitation of these resources is hard
to overestimate I can only hope the new
Oh what no oh come on don't bug out on
me
ah no facility is sufficiently silly to
allow female staff so I can see what
comes with my own eyes okay thank you
thank you for your input on this matter
I'm gonna go over here now and see what
sort of craziness is happening oh yeah
oh oh oh no no
oh it's a guy I gotta not go that way
[Music]
getting tense Oh looks like looks like
miles Upshur isn't doing so good over
there and maybe they don't want to go
over there because [ __ ] it and
apparently for them just saying just
saying please your pad things to go down
down the basement wait a minute Oh am I
gonna see oh I'm excited
well this is gonna be so cool no no no
no not yet I'm not I'm not ready I'm not
ready I gotta go I gotta go go go go
ah they're coming for me I gotta go I
gotta get out of here I gotta get away I
gotta fly away this way I was this going
through the beginning of the game where
I was before this is where I entered the
game as miles offshore that got bolted
down bolted down hardcore wait a minute
what oh hello file yes yes I would love
to read the file level triple black
security protocols including the
chemical restraint physical same
separation adaptive hyperbaric chambers
are to be is at all time in transit
chemical stimulation is highly
recommended for all personnel within
fire armor meters of the patient
attempts at communication should be to
assume to be hallucinations disregarded
facial disfigurement should not be taken
a slight sign of lost acuity they're
physically blind but not on seeing ah so
those are those patients that you were
talking about what is in these wounds
nothing I need to keep movin let's go go
go go
hello bathroom they're gonna be a
jump-scare wedding for being here
someone's taking a crap from the fear
need to learn to steal your bells it's
gonna get a lot worse I think maybe
missing everything got bolted up you
like this security door oh my god I'm in
the beginning I'm a ball for miles I'm
sorry I throw down
my goodness this is terribly exciting
the horribly exciting
this actually is I'm very very
interested in all this is so cool
oh it is so cool I love it
I like it I love it I could go out that
way but what's down here anything down
here that I should know about hearts
blocked off no it's blocked off Alex I'm
honestly like truly I'm not even
sarcastic right now I hope no one mr.
Park
what please no why would I do that
no I was gonna get out you're such a son
of a [ __ ] why would you even try to
kill me know what it's a little late for
that do you think
[Applause]
okay can't say didn't deserve that but I
still got stabbed uh I'm still probably
gonna die because that douchebag stabbed
me I'm still going I am such a badass I
am I am what every horror character
should be because this is awesome
I'm Way better than miles Upshur
nobody's up sure was a badass too he got
his fingers cut off but I broke my leg
and gets stabbed Jesus am I gonna take
miles Upshur scar I'm too excited I need
to stop I'm way way too excited about
this is breaking awesome it's awesome
oh there it is I see it it's right there
I'm coming for you baby I don't need a
camera for this I just need my own eyes
oh my goodness that is amazing that is
amazing
the person who announced all of the bad
things is the only one to escape I am
coming for that glowing door and nothing
will probably stop me maybe come on no
miles miles Oh miles
I see that blackness I see that black
this what I see it no miles please I'm
your buddy I'm not steal your car you
know me I'm let's just try to do Oh
miles
and your friend are now
that is quite a turning radius on that
car can I make it out did I you press
that button it's not going back mr. Park
hmm there's enough hard evidence in that
video file to make a world of [ __ ] for
our friends at Murkoff oh no time out
mess up alive and we've done everything
in our power to cover your tracks
yes but our enemies are twitching and
malicious corporate paranoiacs with
resources you're too moral to imagine
uh-huh you won't be the only target
anyone you care about your wife your
child there'll be nothing to Murkoff but
ways to hurt you okay I need you to
understand the breach you're crossing
here you will do irrevocable damage to
the company you might even get close to
something like justice huh once you
click upload a lot is over everyone you
love is [ __ ] but it's the right thing
to do it's hurting Murkoff worth that
much to you I saw some things man you do
not know the things I saw hell yeah I'd
press that button but my poor wife and
child I press X I'm not using the
console yeah do it
yeah then do it do it kill them I did it
I don't even know if I could poke sorry
sorry I just I don't know I did that but
I don't even know if I couldn't do that
that was awesome
I'm so happy right now wow that was
amazing okay I'm over that okay
all right so unless there's something at
the end of the credits that I want to
see nope that's handy game so either way
that was awesome amazing DLC there I'm
so happy that they made significantly
good DLC that was all like a whole
nother like oh that could have been a
sequel to the game that was amazing or
prequel there's a whole separate game
but that was amazing it is a pretty
affordable DLC for 9 bucks you know I
was always worried like I was saying
like ah DLC for nine bucks the game was
originally twenty or thirty I think when
it came out that was all I was like that
seems like a lot but there was a lot of
game there also Wow
go buy the game if you want to play for
yourself find some secrets that I didn't
find either way
I love that so I hope you liked it too
leave a like for this series if you
enjoyed it thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
video games that I've played in the past
and as always I will see you in the next
video just something a little that's bad
out of the game we get a little more in
fire
yes
awfully good
[Music]
obviously I've been driving into this
woods but I don't know why I don't know
who my character is in relation to
people's house if there is any relation
[Music]